so I am so thrilled to be talking to you
and you said I can call you Emirates
which I love about your wonderful book
totally enjoyed it and you know what I'd
like to just start by asking you the
simple question what is frugality well
as I say in the book the concept of
simplicity itself is not all that simple
frugality is usually understood to mean
living within one's means living on very
few resources saving being the opposite
of extravagant but in writing the book I
began to realize that there's more to
frugality than just that the frugality
is traditionally considered a virtue in
many cultures but it's closely
associated with simple living in general
and then there's many different meanings
of simple living including living within
one's means obviously but also achieving
a degree of self sufficiency perhaps
being close to nature perhaps a certain
kind of purity either aesthetic or
spiritual or model and being independent
enjoying the simple pleasures of life
rather than requiring extravagant
expenditures to enjoy oneself all of
those things are that applied into the
concepts of simplicity by gamma P now
you're a penny pincher yourself right I
am rather my family will vouch for that
I I think to be fair I as I say in the
book I think it's sometimes worthwhile
spending money on something that you
really enjoy that's really valuable for
you the the crucial thing isn't to never
spend money on any kind of luxury at all
the crucial thing is to be self-aware
about what it is you really value what
is really worth spending money on and
what is something where you're just
wasting money or you're just spending it
just because people tell you this is the
kind of thing you ought to be doing or
the kind of thing you ought to be buying
right right you you wrote and and and
throughout your book you talk about a
very
is philosophers you know that 2,000
years worth of folks telling us that we
need to be cheap I embrace the word
cheap but um you're right you say if
frugality equals virtue wisdom and
Happiness why do so many people reject
it then why are we rejecting all these
years of very smart people telling us we
need to be cheap right and that is a
question that's been puzzling
philosophers since the days of Socrates
it seems obvious to many philosophers
Socrates Diogenes Epicurus the Stoics
Thomas More Spinoza Rousseau Thoreau
many others that the good life is the
simple life and sometimes the reason
people will go along with that and say
yeah totally agree but they won't
actually practice what they preach a
good example of that is the Christian
tradition if you I mean one of the great
teachers of simplicity you could save
Jesus and yet many Christians from
Jesus's time onwards have not really
heeded his advice to give everything to
the poor and I think that so what once
there is simple hypocrisy but I don't
think that's the main answer I think
that it's complicated in it and it's
different depending on different periods
I think in the past one of the main
reasons why people for instance did
actively seek wealth were very simple
wealth represented security in a very
insecure world that made a certain
amount of rational sense even though it
was beyond most people most people would
be born poor and died poor until fairly
recent times with the advent of the
Industrial Revolution and then
eventually the consumer age and gun
capitalist society have today it's a
little bit different I think that many
people already enjoy a certain level of
security and now the recreational
opportunities and the vocational
opportunities I'm not greater than they
used to be for many people and so now
it's not so much just soccerway some
money for security say
but it's it's more you know lived life
to the full be what you know be willing
to say it to me and spend money for
great experiences and right right it's
all interesting because those of us who
are and I count the two of us because
we're similar I mean I love to be cheap
and I totally embrace it I tell people
all the time that I breastfed all three
of my kids because the milk was free
cause my kids hate when I say that these
days because they're all teenagers but
you know should I forget it be
considered a moral virtue because I will
be honest I i sometimes kind of can get
on my moral high ground when it comes to
being frugal and I see so much waste so
should we be considered you know better
than those who are wasteful well the
book started with that question should
we consider frugality a virtue and I
found that quite a tricky question at
first because the one is very us in the
softball why did people traditionally
consider for a Galatea virtue one reason
was that it kept people away from
temptation if you lived a very simple
life and just attending to the basic
necessities you won't be tempted to into
decadence and decadent luxury and even
sin another reason was that and I think
this is still true to some extent with
the reason is that to live simply shows
people that you've got the right kind of
values it's very noticeable to me that
when people want to praise someone who
could live a much more in a much more
extravagant way they often point to the
fact that they're living simply Warren
Buffett Buffett one of the richest men
in the world it's often pointed out that
he lives in the house that he bought in
1958 the recently appointed Pope a quite
a deal was made of the fact that he
issued the papal palace and lived in
very simple very simple apartment why
did people say that because they took
that as evidence that to to embrace a
simple lifestyle
was a sure sign of a kind of virtue is
that true I think that there may be some
truth in it because I think that it does
reflect a certain set of values someone
who starts you know buying lots of
private planes lots of gold-plated Rolls
Royces lots of mansions scattered all
over the world you kind of wonder what
are their values I think that's a
reasonable reasonable question so you
know there's a part of your book since
you were talking about how we look at
those who live frugally and we admire
them but right now we're in a period
where we have elected someone who you
know exemplifies access and there's
something that you wrote in your book
that I wanted to ask you about you write
many people many people pay lip service
to the ideals of frugality and
simplicity but you still don't see many
politicians trying to get elected on a
platform of policies shaped by the
principle that the good life is a simple
life on the contrary politicians promise
and government strive to raise their
society's level of production and
consumption the value of continual
economic growth is a given but then you
write the majority of individuals
everywhere seems to associate happiness
more with extravagance than frugality
and that's kind of made me think about
you know Donald Trump's like why does he
appeal to the masses many of whom a
working class lower class middle class
and he he is the example wanted example
of the excess what wine is that do you
think it's a good question I think the
first thing it says he doesn't appeal to
the majority the majority didn't vote
for him but there's no question at all
that people do admire wealth and they do
admire extravagance and there's nothing
particularly new about that you go back
to the to the epic poems of Homer for
instance and you'll see their tremendous
praise for the magnificent wealth of
Agamemnon Menelaus and Priam you
to the Bible and you see some pretty
heavy-duty praise for Solomon's wealth
and in fact in ancient times sometimes
wealth with associated with wisdom in
like in the case of Solomon and so
there's nothing new about people
admiring the rich and the powerful and
where the extravagance is spent for the
benefit of the public then you could
even praise it in the case of Solomon
building a temple for the benefit of the
people or for that matter
Aristotle one of the great Greek
philosophers praises magnificence as a
virtue he doesn't mean by that vulgar
excess I think he'd certainly regard
Trump as guilty of vulgar excess but
magnificence in the sense of generosity
with one's wealth for the benefit of the
people then again that that is that
could be considered a virtue I think in
the case of the recent election of
Donald Trump I mean some people would
often hear this argument that well he
was very rich and that shows that he is
a good businessman and knows how to
handle money I think it's the sort of
bogus argument to be honest and see he
was born into wealth but no why do you
think it's about argument I mean and I
and I love what you just said because
throughout your book you talk about
there's a lot of contradiction on the
one hand we think being frugal so so
Morrow and on the other hand when we see
so much well it's a it could be a bad
thing you know why do we disapprove of
for example extravagant spending I mean
every year there's a survey that comes
out about how much people are spending
on weddings you know thirty thousand
dollars on average which to me is sort
of crazy
I bought a youth wedding dress and my
family was a gasps I mean they were just
like outraged and I said to them listen
you know I think I paid less than a
hundred dollars for the dress I said the
person who were performing she's not
gonna be in my wedding Oh what do I care
but there's this huge contradiction so
why why do we on one hand you know love
the rich but then we disapprove when
they spend crazy well there are good
reasons sometimes to disapprove when
when you know that there are
millions of people homeless that there
are millions of people going hungry that
there are millions of people in dire
need of care and then you see people
spending money on absolute you know huge
amounts of money on something that's
completely trivial you know a special
mansion for their dog to live in or
something like that then you know if
there's a simple philosophical argument
that people Asif is like Peter Singer
make which is that that money could be
much but put to much better use just
just alleviating people's suffering and
misery there's one argument I think I
think there's an aesthetic objection to
it to some extent which is that this
just sort of vulgar that some of the
kind of spending I think you know some
of the kind of excess that is associated
with Donald Trump is just not
particularly pleasant to look at I don't
think I think also again it comes down
back to an expression of values people
take the way that people handle money as
an expression of values now you took
these you give the example of spending
lots of money on on a person's wedding
and it is a peculiar thing that the
people will spend a huge amount of money
on a on a single day wedding celebration
plus the ring plus the catering all this
kind of thing rather than say put a down
payment on a house to me that's not
really very rational but some people
would say well it's an expression of
true love and in fact I've actually
heard I've heard students who have
argued with say this that that how much
you're willing to spend on your fiance
is indeed a measure of how much you love
it that's clearly in a gray belief that
if you want I'm crazy typing crazy it's
a crazy job is one day folks one day I
mean I mean you know the hiring of the
cars I got my cousin the drivers you
don't see so much we didn't have any
liquor I think i'ma drink your own
alcohol what um you'll see okay you'll
see the same thing for instance we
coming up to the Christmas holidays and
some parents will spend huge amounts of
money on their children's Christmas
presents why
well to some extent they sort of feel
that how much they spend is a measure of
how much they love them it's not I mean
that doesn't mean that they don't love
them it's just that it's it's a
misguided value yeah there's you know
you talked about the song okay money
can't buy love except we spent so much
time doing just that spending money to
show people that we love them I mean I
don't I don't understand I'm in the book
you talk about what you know let's stay
on this whole idea of extravagance she
said there's two ways extravagance is
harmful you talk about the knockoff
effect and and being wasteful we come
and wasteful a little bit but tell me
about what's the knockoff effect well
then the danaka defective is really that
all of us in society we we look around
us and particularly we look up we look
up to it to our socioeconomic superiors
to our professional superiors to the
people who are a little bit higher in
various pecking orders than us and it we
to some extent we emulate them and to
some extent we sort of want to be like
them and so let's take it take a
concrete example in higher education
which is the field I work in you look at
the salaries earned by university
presidents these days some of the top
university presidents are making several
million dollars a year now that seems to
me to be ridiculous because after all
universities and colleges and nonprofit
organizations the same as hospitals
hospitals and nonprofit organizations
but some of the big medical facilities
again have CEOs earning in the millions
and that's just their their salary
there's something kind of unhealthy
about that but then you ask why why is
it that say the heads of charities the
heads of medical facilities the heads of
colleges are making so much money not
all of them but some of them and the
answer is because they are basically
saying look how much CEOs in private
industry make I need a I know CEO I
should be getting a comparable income to
to those people right that's an example
of the knock-on effect I hope your
president is an era Neil's got really
good people look at this right
so so oh so we talked about the negative
so when is the stress because it's a
good thing like you you point out two
ways economic growth and I love the part
where you were writing about its use
culture and particularly you mentioned a
city then my husband and I just visit
which was Florence which you know you go
see David and you just spin they're done
at this and and some people paying
pensions like how could you possibly
spend all their money to go to Florence
but so those are two positive things
about extravagance right growth in
culture talk about that a little bit
yeah in the book it's called the wisdom
of frugality and clearly as we started
out saying I I have my own you know
cheapskate wattage tendencies and so I'm
and somewhat inclined to favor frugality
and simple living on the other hand the
book isn't a palenik telling everyone
they must change their life the book is
a genuine attempt to reflect
philosophically and fairly on the pros
and cons of frugality simple living and
also luxury extravagance and I think
when you try to achieve a certain
objectivity you have to recognize that a
huge amount of what we value in our
civilization what we call culture is the
result of extravagance if you want
examples let's say for instance the
music of Hyden and Beethoven and Mozart
they know this was erm this was to some
extent fueled by aristocrats hiring
court orchestras which is pretty
extravagant
the great art of the Renaissance in
cities like Florence was financed
basically by the extravagances of
families like the Medici and none of us
would now wish that it's been different
we don't wish that those hours to Gratz
haven't hired court orchestras and so we
didn't have the music of Mozart or that
those Medicis hadn't spent all that
money so we don't have the art of the
Renaissance we we actually spend our own
hard-earned dollars going to see it and
going to admire it and so there's a
pretty powerful argument in favor of a
kind of extravagance and even today I
mean we're here we I mean New York here
and perhaps while I'm here I'll splash
out and take in the show which for me
would be a big expenditure but why not
it's one of the things that makes New
York and interesting city to visit
that's right you know we talked about
you know one of the positives of
spending is economic growth and in your
book you write talking about sort of
patriotism we are not just constantly
and aggressively encouraged to buy stuff
on credit as for many commodities are
often couple with offers of low-interest
loans but we are even sold at time that
to be an enthusiastic consumer is to be
a good citizen and then you end on this
that consumerism is a form of patriotism
so should we be spend the rest to help
save our country
well I wouldn't endorse that view that
consumerism is a kind of patriotism in a
sense what I'm doing there is quoting
Zand people famously george w bush times
those people to get out there and spend
as a form of patriotism it is a it is a
problem to the people like me who who
generally would like to see more people
embracing the values of simple living i
think a genuine problem is the fact that
our modern economy runs on a lot of
people getting and spending we we do
expect and we do require a fairly high
level of economic activity in order to
keep the the boat afloat so to speak and
i think that's a really difficult and
complicated problem at the same time i
think that there are solutions and i
think that the way things are organized
at the moment there's plenty of money in
the system but the money isn't evenly
distributed and just plenty of work that
needs to be done and yet strangely
there's many people who are unemployed
or underemployed and so all the time in
through the book i'm pushing for a more
ratchet what i just considered to be a
more rational
xiety where if there's work to be done
which there certainly is then and and a
certain people who want to do it and the
resources available to to pay those
people do it then can't reorganize
things in such a way that this can
happen and I think we can but I think it
requires not only a fairly radical
change in government policy but I think
it also requires a change in people's
way of thinking in particular it needs
people need to think again about how
they view work at the moment we we sort
of value hard work we push the work
ethic and we we're proud of how hard we
work everyone says how you're doing and
I'm really busy and that's great
but I actually think that it would be a
more rational society if we could find a
way to redistribute work so that
everyone worked less and there were
fewer people who were seriously
underemployed or unemployed and
therefore requiring social security and
this kind of thing ok this is a this is
a bit of a utopian vision in a sense I
mean in the sense that it's not going to
happen anytime soon at the same time
there's nothing wrong with a utopian
vision which is where the purpose of
which is to say to people hey stop and
think again about how we are doing
everything and how and whether we
couldn't actually organize things in a
more rational way no I love what you're
saying but you know it's just so
difficult economy the US economy is
driven on consumerism I mean every day
there's thousands of messages on you
know on television ads for people to buy
to replace in our homes of a teaming
with stuff I noticed in your book you
talked about self storage space I mean
we have so much stuff that our stuff has
its own place and it's air-conditioned
I mean that it's like it's crazy to me
so talk talk a little bit about this
whole I mean because you know we've been
talking about this contradiction and and
we really are like the split on this
thing on the one hand you know we love
wealth on the other hand we want to be
frugal it's the moral thing to do and
you kind of talk about the saver and
eccentric and two in particular been
free
and who I love and in fact to quote one
of his quotes that I just live by I wait
his quote was but we're up little
expenses a small leak will sink a great
ship that is like I live by that because
my grandmother taught me a lot about
being a penny pincher I'm so there's Ben
Franklin and on the other side of there
just Oscar Wilde who wrote who
apparently died broke I die as I have
lived beyond my means look right can you
just talk about these two people who
live simultaneously I'm totally on bit
you know team Ben that's called a team
[ __ ] and he Oscar um talk a little bit
about that part of your book well yeah
Ben Franklin funny I mean he's the
paradigmatic representative of the one
who says live within your means and he
famously did live within his means and
he and his wife lived very frugally and
there's a funny anecdote of how one time
his wife decided that he really did
deserve slightly better cutlery and
slightly better crockery and they they
moved up from a crude you know Putin mug
or something like this
Oscar Wilde is famously kind of decadent
who you know was basically lived for the
moment and said screw the future and at
least with Oscar Wilde at least he can't
accuse him is hypocrisy there's a kind
of it is a it is a form of life and if
you if we go with John Stuart Mill and I
want to encourage people to experiment
in lifestyles then I guess Oscar Wilde
was an experiment in life in a lifestyle
and you know what he didn't die very
happily but that was perhaps more the
you know to do with the the times that
he lived in rather than the particular
way did he lived that you started out
the question talking about consumerism
and I think that what I want to say
there is is this you're absolutely right
we are bombarded every day from all
sides with adverts telling us to buy
this buy that and buy the other and the
basic message of all those adverts is
that if you buy it you'll be happy you
will be more attractive you'll be sexier
you'll learn you'll have better
vacations
we'll be more likely to you know make
make riches or whatever the question you
have to ask there is is any of that true
is it actually true that consumerism
produces happiness it seems to me that
there's plenty of research on this that
points to the fact that it's just not
true what if there's a consensus among
social scientists now more or less which
is this that to get out of poverty
certainly improves your level of
happiness to achieve you know basic kind
of level of comfort and security
that's very desirable and your happiness
will increase but up to it but it but
beyond a certain point it really doesn't
make much difference there I think they
figure that they tout in these gauges is
a household income know about seventy
thousand dollars a year and I think that
I mean that that seems quite high to me
actually it seems to me that the
question to ask about all the
consumerism is is just that is it
actually doing what it promises is it
making people happier and I just don't
think it is I'd actually think it it
quite likely breeds discontent an
interesting fact that I've been puzzling
over that and I don't have really an
answer to this but it's something for
anyone to think about is this that in
the recent election and of course you
know millions of people voted for Donald
Trump and people who voted for Donald
Trump would often described as angry
angry with the system angry the system
yet the average income of the household
of a Donald Trump voter was seventy-two
thousand dollars according to the polls
that I've read and then you wonder why
are these people angry because after all
seventy two thousand dollars as a
household income puts you in you know
the top view percenter percentage points
of the world economy and it means
actually you're among the richest people
have ever lived in history so why are
why are people who are really by any
normal standards very comfortably off
why are they angry so why are they angry
do you think as I said I've been
puzzling over it and I'm not sure I
think
that the answer is probably complicated
and it has to do to some extent with the
fact that it's not just your objective
circumstances that determine how you
feel it's also your perceived
circumstances what you perceive about
yourself you may indeed be among the
richest people in history but it may not
feel like that because as I said earlier
you tend to compare yourself not with
people below you or with people who are
worse off than you which includes people
in the past but you compare yourself
with perhaps where you're expected to be
or where you'd like to be or or perhaps
with the people who are just a bit
better off than you right and you're
always going to be someone better off
than you right because I mean well could
it also be that there's just so much
pressure on our income these days I mean
I think it does tie into you're looking
at we always talk about trying to live
like the Joneses well we find out
Joneses or just as brokers we are but
that it cost so much and that that bed
golden ring of the middle-class life
cost so much and any disruption in your
income I miss paycheck one illness you
know forget it is not an issue because
you're going to be frugal you do you
think that's it as well I think that has
a lot to do with it yet that there it's
not just a matter of anger it's a matter
of insecurity and I think there is a lot
of insecurity in even in a wealthy
country like the United States a lot of
insecurity and with good reason
just like you say in many places where
all the jobs are the big cities rents
and housing costs can be extraordinarily
high so you really do have to make quite
a bit of money in order to just avoid
being homeless I think that there's also
the fact that you know many countries
like in the United States we don't have
the greatest you know Social Security
system our health care system I I'm a
sort of unreconstructed you know
socialistic liberal type I actually
admire countries like Denmark which
provide people with a very secure signet
they guaranteed health care it's paid
for
taxes they're guaranteed decent housing
they're guaranteed a decent education
yes you have high taxation although it's
not particularly higher than in the
United States it's just that it's a more
efficient use of resources my own view
is that I'd like to see us move in that
direction towards trying to ensure that
everyone can feel easy can feel less
anxious about the basics being taken
care of because I think that that way
people could in fact reorient their
values and say okay okay I don't have to
worry about health care I don't have to
worry about my old age I don't have to
worry about my kids education
so maybe I'm willing to move maybe I can
choir a different career maybe I can
maybe I can also just live more simply
and you know do things in my community
and satisfy myself as simple pleasures
absolutely anxiety people suffer yeah
anxiety people suffer is is one reason
for for the for the press for the stress
yeah definitely a lot of stress out
there you know I was struck at two
places in your book where you live
synonyms for both being frugal and
extravagance and it kind of set it up
the difference between a miser and a
saver and so I live I didn't know this
action I should have probably known it
for my old English classes but in
Dante's Inferno both misers and spring
therus our place in the fourth circle of
hell
what how are they alike I mean how why
why why should they see himself I why
during the why they're in hell I guess
because both of vices how they're alike
I'm not I'm not sure they are alike
really I mean they're just they're
they're pretty differently they do seem
to be to be opposites it's interesting
that it with my silliness I mean again
that although like you I'm I tend to be
very you know much in favor of them
living and being frugal in this kind of
things there is that there is that
concern that you you have to be aware of
that taken to an extreme and not even
that much of an extreme but you can
actually fall into that trap of being
miserly even even becoming kind of
avaricious you know being a bit too
penny pinching it can even become
irrational you can you know I've known
people like this where let's say there
aren't oliday when if they are known
people like this I think I sometimes
been like this you're on holiday in a
certain place there's a sight to see you
want to see it and then you time to find
out the emission charges let's say
twenty dollars and you say twenty
dollars no way I'm not paying $20 for
that you know especially when you've got
you know spouse and two children in tow
and the whole thing would cost family
discount
$60 yeah you know forget it and so but
then later on you kind of think you know
I won't ever be there again that was my
one chance to see that great building
that you know going to that Museum or
whatever and yeah you know $60 later on
later on in life you're not going to
miss that $60 whereas you would have had
that experience and so sometimes I think
the the habit of penny-pinching the
franklin esque tendency that me and you
both share can sometimes lead you to
make actually bad decision yeah I'm
going to answer a by sacrificing a
valley little around me yeah you're just
subscribe oh you've done it as well yeah
oh my gosh we just came back from Italy
and I I said those exact same words what
that cost what where in Italy and my
husband the whole trip was like we're in
Italy like really we're not going to go
broke like all right cause we really
honey come and because you do cross that
line oftentimes you cross the line over
from being frugal a penny pincher to
being a miser and it really is a
difference correct I mean and sometimes
people will say that I'm miserly I'm not
and I try to fight against it but there
where is that line I mean how do you how
do you be fooled I mean I think that's a
lot of people are paying clinchers are
to be watching this they're scared to
death you don't want to be wasteful you
want to be good stewards over your money
you mentioned Solomon and includes the
acids you know considered to be wise and
rich but there is a part where he talks
about how he spent so much because he
just wanted and it's that sort of point
where it was just you know and the wind
it was so much so where is that line
between being a miser and being frugal
well like with nothing I don't think
there's a clear-cut line it's a you know
it's a spectrum and I think that what
one aspect of being a miser would be to
be ungenerous so you know if you're
never willing to give money to any
anyone else or to lend money or to give
money to charity or anything like that
that's that's again that's the downside
of being excessively frugal and I think
that there is you know you can try and
cultivate that behavior the way that in
many churches many religions you know
there's a there's a sort of obligation
to give regularly give give to charity
gives arms this kind of thing and one of
the ideas of that is a pretty good idea
it's just cultivate the habit cultivate
the habit of being somewhat generous not
necessarily extravagantly generous but
somewhat generous as a kind of check
against that the self-interest interest
a tendency to or wait to hold on to
everything yourself I like like a finger
yeah all right I think can well and I
think many people who are frugal
actually are very can be very generous I
don't you know many many of my students
when I've talked about these matters
with them they'll cite you know
grandparents or great-grandparents who
who have sort of been raised on
Depression era values and who even in
old age will absolutely not
shake the habit of saving every penny of
being you know being very very concerned
about waste and yet those people are not
ungenerous they just they just don't
want to waste money and there is a
difference isn't there between between
way
setting money like spending money on
things that you don't need and being on
generous which is refusing to part with
money even for good causes that's good I
love that I love that I think the kind
of tight what I am is definitely one
that I really dislike waste I for
instance just a personal thing I can't
stand throwing food away I really really
don't like throwing food away I'm with
you I'll make strange
I'll make strange meals of leftovers
some strange combination leftover that
my wife will never eat let's just be
creative I love it I love it in our
house we have called leftover night
because I'm like you and it's like you
know if it's starting to look a little
fuzzy I'm like honey that's called
penicillin that's gonna be good for you
but leftover night we take out you know
your large family of five and so you
know there's leftovers it's only enough
to say maybe two and so Robbie in the
week there's like two here three there
servings and so I open the refrigerator
door I take them all out and put them on
the counter and I yell to the house left
overnight and then you just hear this
under the resident River because of
course they're better left over the ones
that are later in the week and kitchen
so so I totally get it but that kind of
rings me through this I wanted you to
tell the listeners or viewers can you
just define the term in your book you
use a frugal zealot what is that a
frugal zealot I take the term from a me
decision who she was the person who
created and wrote and and and put out
the for a long time the tightwad Gazette
which was a sort of newsletter that came
out once a month cost the dollar I
subscribed to it when I heard about it
eventually the the newsletters were all
compiled into I think two volumes that
you can still buy and sharpen she always
find herself be the frugal zealot or the
frugal dealer and a frugal fella is it
actually Michelle someone like you
really who really sort of is very very
aware of where you can save money is
constantly concerned to avoid waste
avoid
Cerie extravagance and just sort of
constantly you know looking to sort of
take your lunch to work instead of
instead of buying it out make you you
know make your own coffee instead of
buying buying it out exactly you know
turning off the lights to save that last
bit of energy bill throwing your own
potatoes if that's all that kind of
thing yeah I used to charge my children
a dollar they leave my lights on in the
house and I'd go to their house and
secure me a dollar you owe me a dollar
they started turning my lights out
what's that I've done so this thing
about you know turning your lights out
your you know composting the food and
all this kind of thing is every little
bit helps I I think I think it's you
know if it's you know every small action
you take goes to constitute a way of
living and if enough people share that
way of living then I think it does
actually no shift the world in the
direction that makes more sense right
you know I'll have to make a confession
because the next question I want to ask
you is it's simple it's simple living
always green environmentally you know
sound and my husband and I redoing our
bedroom and you know we had to move
stuff out for the painters and as frugal
as I am I have to say I was quite
ashamed at all the stuff that I've
accumulated you know books things I
can't throw away and I just and it
really pained me because some of the
stuff you can't recycle and I mean I
actually got a moment of depression
because I felt like I just even as
frugal as I am you know I'm still
wasteful and um I'm not as green as I
should be but if Semple living always
green no I wish it was with it but it's
not in the last chapter of the book I
addressed this the the environmental
argument for simple living clearly I
mean there is a pretty obvious
environmental argument which is that
simple living involves almost
just by default it involves reducing
one's ecological footprint you reduce
waste you turn off the light so you know
save energy this kind of thing you might
run one car instead of two cars etc
exactly you you reduce the need for
factories to produce items because you
tend to buy them secondhand rather than
new there's lots of ways in which you
can reduce your ecological footprint on
the other hand there are parts of green
living
sorry parts of frugal living which or
the lifestyle that's associated with it
which aren't particularly green in my
case for instance I live in a rural
location which means I live in a in a
detached house in a family house it's
far more efficient to live in a city
apartment surrounded on all sides by the
departments it's farmer a farmer
efficient and in the same way it's
farmer you know I am living in a rural
area where there's not very good public
transport you drive a lot more than say
if you lived in the city where there's
good good transit system and you um use
public transport like millions of others
so there's ways of there's parts of the
lifestyle associated with simple living
certainly where it inspires it's
associated with country living which is
not all that green yeah I know what you
mean I live in the suburbs too and I you
know when I work from home alive for
that very reason I first of all he
driving but also the cost of it and the
gas and the you know the emissions
really you know and we see you you what
what if everybody embraced frugality
what everybody thought like you and I I
sort of imagined that and and what would
our economy look like what but what the
country look like what wouldn't there be
loss of jobs and what if everybody was
cheap right yeah I consider that if
everyone suddenly rushed out and bought
the book and decided to go on a you know
let's say they followed your advice and
went on a three-week financial fast
right before Christmas
Hey and yet the economy would collapse
and it would be a disaster for retailers
and therefore knock-on effect for
producers as well and so
I think that's something you have to
recognize at the same time as I said
we've you know before it also worth
asking whether the kind of world we want
to create is the world where it's just
more and more getting and spending more
and more production and consumption it
seems to me that most you know huge
amounts of people millions of people as
you said earlier they've got all the
stuff they need they don't need more
stuff we just don't you know most people
many many people in a society like the
u.s. have more stuff than they can
really handle and so but it's true that
you can't just sort of turn the thing
around overnight so I think that that's
actually one of the ways one of the
places where philosophy has a value
because philosophy is first about sort
of getting people to reflect hard on the
way things are the way we do things our
current practices our current ways of
thinking and not to not as it were to
not suddenly reverse direction overnight
which might cause I can train wreck but
rather sort of say okay could we could
we connect reorient our values away from
so much consumption and production
towards embracing simple lifestyles
valuing the you know the simpler
pleasures rather more and therefore
inevitably you know redistributing work
redistributing wealth to some extent so
that everyone can share yeah it's it's a
I mean what I'd call for would be not a
sort of overnight transformation which
like I said might be investor rather a
reorientation of values you know it's
interesting there's two things you
talked about in what you just said about
no relearning the way we work and one
thing that I've been writing a lot about
and my column for the post is
encouraging people to live together not
any not single people but families you
know multi-generational households
because housing is so expensive I mean I
try to make the argument for example
when when college students those who
you're teaching leave I think it's
perfectly fine and they should move home
and live home for a while that everybody
can afford their own house
but that's a hard sell don't you think I
mean you you started a book about
philosophers and and henry david thoreau
and ben franklin but that's a hard sell
in this economy and out in our culture
of you know more you got to have your
own apartment get on you have a house
how do we make that argument that it's
okay when we've been told kick them out
you know they need to be out on their
own
whoa if they're on their own then they
need a whole household of stuff it it's
a problem I think that for many people
in certainly in you know modernized
societies one of the biggest problem is
is simply housing costs housing housing
costs explain a lot of people's
difficulties and dissatisfactions
housing costs in places like New York
Boston London San Francisco Paris just
take up such a huge amount of people's
income that they really you know have
they have to work very hard and they
don't have much time you know much money
for anything else there isn't I don't
have a simple solution to that I do
think that I think that government
should see it as a problem and should
address it and one of the obvious ways
would be to invest large amounts of
money in creating subsidized public
housing so just to bring down housing
costs the first thing he said though was
talked about living more communally and
I think that again this is a case where
we could we could benefit from thinking
a little bit outside the box one of the
reasons why I think for many people
college days are such a happy memory
it's because it's a time when they live
communally and I don't you know don't
just living in a family but they lived
with a whole group of friends and it's
very communal setup and again there's
plenty of social science research on
this in in some places like again like
Denmark and Sweden places the people
experiment with them
communal living where perhaps perhaps
seven or eight families share a compound
share a comfort and they they perhaps
you might if you're in this kind of
communal set up you might cook two days
a month and you might wash up two days a
month the rest of the time you know you
just
so to show up for the den time and in
the evening there's communal activities
and this kind of things it's um it's a
departure from the nuclear family the
nuclear family has become very much you
know part of our sort of cultural DNA
but I I'd love to see us kind of
questioning that a little bit more
particularly when it comes to the way in
which children are raised when the way
in which we we deal with people in old
age because people in within old age
suffer terribly from loneliness many you
know millions do and wouldn't it be kind
of nicer when did we perhaps a
worthwhile experiment try to bring the
generations together in communal living
arrangements where old people had young
people all around them and for that
matter the young people instead of being
isolated in their nuclear families were
you know constantly mixing and mingling
with people with many generations I love
that idea I love that they do my husband
I practice as we always have someone
living with us at one point or another
and I think I'm again mother with it
therefore the philosopher who's the
pardon there is curious because Epicurus
did in fact set up a commune in his
garden outside Athens it was a subject
of a great deal of gothic people thought
there all kinds of kinky goings-on in
there
but actually what if the kuro spent his
time doing was writing studying and
eating communal meals with friends and
going for walks with them basically he
just he said that of all things that are
necessary for happiness the most
important by far is friendship yeah and
I think he was someone who had really
had his values it's great well that's a
that's a hard sell you know that right
um I love this part and I know we're
getting closer to the end I just enjoyed
this conversation so much and anytime
you talk about penny-pinching I love it
the subset subchapter is simple living
allows one to work less and enjoy more
leisure and you write the more forego
the more frugal you live the less money
you will need and the more you are
likely to save either way this will
reduce your need to work thereby
increasing your leisure time and hence
your
Venis Wow so basically work less you can
have more and and and live better that
why are we not doing that well you've
put your finger on some of the problems
the fact is that we don't live in
isolation from our society and if all
around you housing costs are going up
and you did you're not fortunate enough
to own and they're paid off your own
house then you either have to swallow
those increased housing costs or you
have to go and live somewhere else
and I think that in general the the
problem people face is that to live in
the modern world requires a certain
whole set of expenditures that you might
prefer not to make meaning you where I
live you're pretty much required to have
a car if you don't have a car you're off
the grid increasingly people are
required to have a cell phone you
practically required of a smartphone if
you don't have a smartphone
you're off the grid you won't have any
friends you know you won't be able to to
meet up with people you won't be able to
keep track of things but that means
you've got to pay for a phone plan it
means you've got to pay for a car
inspection car insurance and this kind
of thing
so this you know one of the things is
that around we live in this we don't
live in isolation from our society we
live in bedded within it and our society
pretty much requires us to shell out in
various directions you don't really have
a choice about it and and that's why
it's it's not easy the one way you can
yeah I think if people were really if
people really did want to embrace a
lifestyle which involved working less
and spending less I think that probably
they'd they'd move to places in place in
the world or places in our country where
where the basically housing costs are
very cheap and living is very cheap but
these are across the least fashionable
places and if you're a young person
looking for opportunity you're probably
not going to move from the exciting city
with all kinds of opportunities to a
remote rural location
which you know people many people see
the back of a cultural backwater so you
know you wrote this book you're talking
about for gallery do you see a sea
change is there more movement after 24
2000 years of philosophers advocating
for this is there a great change towards
it do you think I would like to say yes
we're witnessing the beginning of a sea
change I honestly doubt if that is true
what I think is true is that we've had
the consumer society now for two or
three generations and I think that
people have become more aware of the
problems with consumerism I think that
we there's been a fair amount of good
serious thoughtful criticism of
consumerism and materialism and I think
that in that sense we are a little bit
more self-aware perhaps a little bit
more self-critical and I think that
maybe not another sea change but perhaps
there could be a gradual drift towards
what I called earlier a reorientation of
values towards them the good things of
the simple life I think it would be a
little bit analogous to perhaps the the
way in which say with our eating habits
for the longest period of time most
people didn't have enough to eat and
then after the Second World War for the
first time really in in history you know
the majority of society had pledged to
eat and then you know we got you know
fast food and junk food and this kind of
thing and so we started to eat more than
was really good for us because in a way
you know it's in our DNA to to grab the
food when we can because you never know
when the next famine is going to come
well you know the next family is not
likely to come very soon and so we
perhaps started eating more you know and
ingesting more colors than was good for
us the result of course is a demikhov
obesity but we're aware of that now and
so we start taking measures to sort of
kind of try to deal with it
and
maybe were aware of that now with
respect to the academic of too much
stuff too much materialism and so we're
perhaps beginning to take steps to deal
with that the first step is always
self-awareness self-criticism and you
know just and philosophy right it's
interesting you talk about that because
when you taught the class which I assume
that's where not as soon but when I read
that that's where the book came out of
there was some criticism about this
wasteful class about frugality where it
was they're not right okay so I am quite
a few years ago I taught a class at
Alfred University where I teach it was
one evening a week and it was called
tight watery the good life on a dollar a
day it was what we call an honors class
which was meant to be kind of
intellectual fun which is there's a
serious component to it but we can also
have some fun there really was a serious
component to it and we read
Epicurus we've read the Stoics we read
the ROE and other contemporary
philosophers like Juliet Shore critics
of consumerism and materialism and then
there were there were a few classes that
were a little bit more fun we we did a
and feel click to a to yard sales and
then did a show-and-tell we the students
watch the video and how to cut hair and
then practice cutting each other's hair
we had at the end of the semester a
class banquet where everyone had to
bring a sort of depression-era recipe
and we tried to feed ourselves off under
$10 and and so that there was that sort
of less serious component to the class
but I would resist anyone who said I
would reject the accusation that the
class was a waste of time or foolish I
think actually even the the law the less
theoretical more personal parts of the
class like we had a couple of classes on
personal finance where the students
learn about Roth IRAs and dollar cost
averaging and that kind of thing and
those are actually fairly important
things that people know that right right
what what do you want people and I'm
good I'm sorry obviously the Stewart
students like the class and I never met
a parent to object it to the class
either oh that's good I certainly
wouldn't ah what do you hope people
get from the book it's very academic but
it's also I mean your your your
philosopher is the very cell of
philosophical and I found myself nodding
quite a bit and yeah yeah yeah but what
do you help for the average person to
get if should they pick up the book and
they should I would say first of all I'd
like them to enjoy philosophizing I
actually think that philosophy is is
obviously it's a serious discipline but
I think philosophy can also be enjoyable
and entertaining it's it's actually fun
to think hard about problems like why do
we why should we think that frugality is
a virtue what does it mean to live
simply how do we define these terms what
are the arguments in favor of what are
the arguments against it where does the
balance lie but all the things we've
been talking about over the last hour I
think those are interesting themselves
it's enjoyable to think about it but I
think it is important as well because
what we're talking about here to to cite
Plato it's not a trivial matter it's the
question is how we should live how we
ought to live as individuals as families
as communities as a society and I would
hope not that everyone will read the
book and become a card-carrying
certified pipe wad necessarily but
certainly that they would reflect on
their own values both the values they
theorize with and the values that they
live by and perhaps orient themselves
towards you know less waste and agree
with Epicurus that of all things in life
most important thing is friendship I'm
mad anyway I can I set it that's so
great it's been a pleasure to talk to
you about this Emrys west high flow the
book is the wisdom of Ferg ality why
less is more
more or less thank you so very much it's
been a pleasure